we've got a voicemail number it's two
one nine two david p here's a voicemail
about the entire sort of MSNBC sam cedar
thing take a listen to this hey David I
was wondering so I know that you're pals
with a lot of people on MSNBC people
like crochets and Sam cedar and you've
also spoken favorably about Joe
Scarborough and Mika Brzezinski
and yeah so uh surely you know that
MSNBC is just the propaganda arm of the
DNC right and I'm sure you know that
please tell me you don't like that
program that you don't get your
information from that program because
that stuff is just straight corporate
garbage yeah all right I don't know
where this guy is getting this stuff the
only person I'm friends with at MSNBC is
the is Sam cedar who's marginally an
MSNBC contributor and no longer because
they're not renewing his contract
I've never exchanged even a single word
or tweet with Chris Hayes Joe
Scarborough and Mika Brzezinski when
when have I been praising them I've said
some times that they were right about
something they said yeah maybe defending
them against Donald Trump calling Joe
crazy Joe or calling him a murderer
whatever else yeah I don't know where
this guy's getting this stuff and I've
been very clear that MSNBC and Fox News
are both corporate media stations which
have made different editorial decisions
full-stop I don't know maybe you've got
me confused with someone else maybe Kyle
kolinsky or Genki you I have no idea who
you think I am because I didn't say any
of that stuff and I don't know any of
these people and quite frankly I don't
know that they'd even respond to me if I
tweet it to them that's how low I am i
think on the list of priorities for
chris hayes and joe scarborough or
whoever bet they know who you are you
think i think so be interesting
interesting to hear about that we've got
a great bonus show for you today but
what i don't have time for is time to
tell you what's on the bonus show but
trust me folks it's a good one today